Hello network!
You know that I like videos about voting.
Here are some that can help organizations
Optimize its election method
But normal people also need better election methods.
Suppose you and a group of people are deciding
What should I eat for dinner?
And there are three options:
Meat shed - all day meat
Vegetable Villa - I hope you like lettuce
And the burger house - forever burger
(including meatless burgers?)
Just ask people to choose their favorite
Normally, three carnivores will be produced.
Now you can take advantage of the following
I have talked about better methods before.
But really, who wants to use
Pen, paper and nerd
To solve one can
Questions that can be answered in less than 30 seconds?
So here is one of the fastest in a group
And no need for anything
Don't blink! Otherwise you will miss it!
If you want a meat shed, raise your hand!
If you want a hamburger house, please raise your hand!
If you want a restaurant, please raise your hand!
boom!
End of election
Hamburg House
This time, everyone has a living
What is the difference? Give more than once
Voting opportunity
If you are in a group and want to go quickly
Different choices to make a decision
Then you should do this
Stop talking is usually earth-shaking
such as
In the classroom
Children! We are going to watch a movie today!
Because, I can't...
So start now
Terminator 2's raise hand
Spirited Away
Waley's hand raised
OK, it is the power
Lazy tips! If you are responsible for this election
You don't have to pay attention
Those who want to vote more than once
An aspiring dictator who subverts democracy
Cast more than once
Is the focus
So next time you are in a group of people
I want to decide something
Don't just ask what they want most.
To ask all the OK
Is the best way to decide things quickly
And don't need pen, paper or nerd